I just heard about rejuvenation. Some say it is great for healing.
Another site said to avoid it. If you have leaky gutter Candida,
overgrowth, if you heard of this, you think it's good.
Or gut healing is important to use gluten-free grain or is gluten-negligible in
the finished product. So rejuvenation is something you make.
It's a fermented grain is what it is. You ferment a grain.
Now, you could use wheat berries, you could use oat berries, you could use
quinoa. If you're going to do it, I think it's important to use a gluten-free grain
like quinoa. And are there benefits to fermented
products? Yes, there's great benefits to fermented products.
If you have yeast issues, should you use fermented products?
No, you shouldn't. So yes, you should not do it with Candida.
I wouldn't say that you can't do it with leaky gut.
But I wouldn't do it with, if you have a Candida, overgrowth or you think you do.
And some people do well with fermented products like that.
And some people, it makes things worse. So you just, you know,
it could give you a clue of what's going on. This person might not have no idea
that they have Candida because they have no, you know,
vaginal Candida, they don't even think that they have intestinal Candida.
They've never even had any symptoms like that. And then they do a,
it's even drinking a kombucha or something like that because it's on the order of a kombucha.
So they drink a kombucha and it really upsets their stomach. Well, that's a hint that you
could have some yeast overgrowth that you don't even, you didn't even know.
So Candida is more common than you think.
And the person could have no other external symptoms of Candida.
You know, they don't have a white tongue or they don't have any vaginal yeast growth or anything
like that, but they have a intestinal Candida. But I would definitely go with a gluten-free grade.
Is the gluten in the finished product? I would say yes, it is still.
So I would go with a gluten-free grade if you're going to try it.